grand service public unifié et laïc de
l'éducation nationale sera mise en place
mises en place ont négocié sans
spoliation ni monopole en annonçant le
15 mars 80 son intention de réunifier le
système éducatif
le candidat à l'elysée françois
mitterrand se doutait-il qu'il ouvrait
le dossier le plus sensible sans doute
le plus difficile du septet depuis deux
ans et demi la réalisation d'un service
public et laïque d'éducation n'a cessé
d'être l'objet d'un débat passionnel
janvier 82 le ministre de l'éducation
nationale entame les premières
consultations en avril
première réponse au ministre plus de
cent mille personnes réclament à la
porte de pantin
le maintien de l'enseignement privé
celui de l'éducation de notre jeunesse
touche au plus vite la nation au sens où
un enjeu politique
le 9 mai au bourget fête du centenaire
de l'école publique devant 300 mille
personnes le premier ministre rappelle
l'objectif du gouvernement le 20
décembre alain savary présente ses
propositions
les écoles privées deviennent
établissements d'intérêt public avec un
statut particulier les enseignants sont
intégrés dans la fonction publique pour
les parents le libre choix des écoles
est limité
l'objectif de cette entreprise n'est pas
de contraindre il est de procéder par
étapes à une rénovation d'ensemble du
système national d'enseignement dès le
lendemain l'enseignement catholique
rejette ces propositions elles
conduisent dit-il à la suite si de
l'école privée
les négociations sont ajournés les
partisans de l'école laïque ne cachent
pas leur déception et leur impatience le
2 septembre 83 à lille le premier
ministre relance le débat il est clair
mesdames et messieurs aujourd'hui que
les lois debré et guermeur sont
complètement inadaptés à la situation
actuelle
alain savary est donc conduit à
présenter de nouvelles propositions à la
veille de sa déclaration
deux événements importants un sondage
paris match bba montre que 71 % des
français sont favorables à l'existence
de l'enseignement privé
d'autre part les déclarations des
responsables de l'enseignement
catholique et du comité national
d'action laïque fixe chacun pour son
camp les règles du jeu
on ne peut pas céder sur le choix libre
des parents par rapport à l'école on ne
peut pas céder sur l'autonomie des
établissements dans l'expression de leur
vie associative et on ne peut pas céder
sur les conséquences c'est-à-dire
finalement le projet d'un établissement
qui chez nous est de nature
confessionnelle ce qui est négociable et
nous y restons presse et les voies et
moyens
grâce auquel on pourra installer en
france un grand service public unifié et
laïc d'éducation ont toujours dit
c'est-à-dire l'amélioration générale du
système éducatif français
ça c'est négociable ce qui n'est pas
négociable et il faut le répéter
aujourd'hui même c'est le but à tam qui
est le service public unifié et laïc
sauf à vouloir perpétuer les privilèges
exorbitants que la droite politique a
octroyé à un enseignement
particularistes et sauf pour un
gouvernement de la gauche à se renier
est il nécessaire de préciser après ses
déclarations que les négociations qui
vont s'ouvrir au ministère de
l'éducation nationale seront long et
très difficile
les uns veulent changer les règles du
jeu les autres rêvent de garder le statu
quo on ne voit pas comment alain savary
malgré sa diplomatie légendaire peut
espérer mettre tout le monde d'accord